私もい今回の動画も面白いから最まで見て
ね人めちゃをほってける
ぞバンカ
ラジオ私の名前はさつきこの子は妹のメイ
普段は可愛い妹なんだけどついたぞ新しい
絵だ
あわフロー
家壊れたらみんな怪我するよえい怖くない
わんなんだこれは
あとてもサイコパスな
のよしついたぞ新しい絵だ
わ
あああ
[音楽]
取ったあ取ったはんいやいやいやこれは
真っ黒クロスケが出たな真っ黒クロスケ
そここじすすとほりだらけにしちゃうのよ
あ足の朝まだかええ夕食かケバブまるまる
食いてえなおばあちゃんはボケてるし無視
していいよメの手が汚いしそろそろ風呂に
するかはい
でもなんだか私怖いわここ暗いし変な
生き物もいるしメイ怖くないもん
うわみんな笑ってみな追っかないのは逃げ
ちゃう
からどうする真っ暗だ仲間が1人やられた
絶対にやり返すぞ任せろ俺が完璧な計画を
立てた敵は取る準備はいいな行くぞ
ら俺のことは置いて
いけあとは任せたぞバっ
た逃げろ
マキラカス出ておい
でここなら大丈夫だ
だ変なとめちゃを発ちくる
[音楽]
ぞバグり
クリ
[音楽]
リあなたは誰わ大きい
お腹ていうのね私は
メイうるさいあとメイちゃんねちゃんと
喋れるでしょすすいませんあやって欲しい
ことがある
のともしのお菓子あなたがから盗んできて
いいいらっしゃいいらっしゃいそれ
どうただの万引だよ叩きするわけじゃない
んだから芋引いてないでやりなカメラも
なくて足つかないしでも捕まったらどう
すれば捕まっても軽犯罪だからすぐ出れる
よ白切ればいいのスニッチだけはしないで
ね
[音楽]
たたろ
おちょちょっと待てと
ろいい大人がさ働きもしないで万引なんて
みともないよね実はめちゃ
にやっぱなんでもないですじゃあ現行反対
ってこと
であいつにやらされたん
です
何歩け
[音楽]
メイ怖くない
もん幼稚園の女の子が脱獄しましただって
いつでも逃げれるんだもんと言っていた
そうです刑務所を放火した後近くの森に
逃走した模様ですあなたは
誰あた
ていうな
ねこれで
おらカンター1人で歩けまたかこれ丸田で
もねえななんだこれおばあちゃんちゃ
面白くないお姉ちゃんのとこ連れてって
だめだよいい子にしてねえ
と逆らったな
[音楽]
ごめんな姉ちゃんのとこ行くて気がね
もん家で大人しく待ってろよ
ちび
がだからこねでかし
て
ほらいっ
[拍手]
て急雨困ったね
んあ
ありがとうおめえにあげる傘は
ねでも濡れちゃうじゃ
[音楽]
ないバカ惚れ刺すんじゃないわ
よすきすき好き好き好き
好き私たち好き同士
ね最近お姉ちゃん遊んでくれない
[音楽]
な
ただいまあれメイはまだ帰ってないぞメイ
がいないメイがいないカタえケトかこっち
かあっちのケトかあ僕がギリギリな
んすメイがいないの一緒に探して
イイイ
メイ
メイメイ
[音楽]
ちゃんこりゃめちゃんのサダか
かたメがもしかしたら沈んじゃったのかも
[拍手]
わしの入れ全部金張りしたらラッパー見で
抜けてねえかあれカタはカタ
はめい
ちゃんでパドラ課金すんのこれたまんねえ
なよかったメが無事で
あとりなんて古臭いことやってないでパズ
でもやればメイそんなこと言わない
のし私はなれいやだ
[音楽]
ら
どろあつい
た暇だからこれで遊ぼうか
な隣のめいちゃんめいちゃんえめいちゃん
めい街の中に
遊ん
でる隣のめちゃんめ
ちゃんめいちゃんめいちゃんよ壊したい時
あなたに
れれな
出会い幼稚園の女の子が真黒クロスを使い
移動しながらをて
容疑者はメイ黒く染めたら楽しいなどと教
してい
ますこりゃすごいな私のせいだはメのこと
寂しくさせちゃったからどうしようかろ
トロにお願い
しようこりゃすごいなメを止めてほしいの
やはい
どんぐりれ
[音楽]
よメイもうやめてうるさいあ
うこういう時は笑ってみなっっかないのは
逃げちゃうから
わはは
お父さんこりゃすごいな
メイ思い出して人間を
思いやるメイ弱くない
もん次行く
[音楽]
よろもう
いやまだ賛は
あるあんな怪物でもまだ幼稚遠征2時半は
お昼寝の時間寝た瞬間を拘束するの
すやすやすやすや今
[音楽]
よあれ今までのは夢そそうだよだたらも
ネバの真っ赤カスケもいなかったのか
はあ夢だ
けど夢じゃなかっ
た
わちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしくはチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録